bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
d'écouter l'audition de Francis Delon
devant la commission des lois Francis
Delon et l'homme que François Hollande a
choisi pour prendre la tête de la future
Commission chargée de contrôler le
recours aux techniques de surveillance
c'est-à-dire la structure chargée de
surveiller les écouter le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que cette nomination
est contestée Francis Delon en effet été
secrétaire général de la Défense
nationale jusqu'en 2014 ces opposants
lui reprochent d'avoir à ce titre mise
en place un vase système de d'espionnage
pour la DGSE système qu'on lui demande
aujourd'hui de contrôler le gouvernement
en effet fait de cette future Commission
la pierre angulaire de sa loi sur leur
enseignement en échange de moyens
d'enquête accrue pour les services de
sécurité l'exécutif a promis de
renforcer le contrôle de leurs activités
Jean-Marie Delarue l'ancien contrôleur
général des prisons avait été un temps
pressenti pour ce poste
vous n'avez pas caché devant les
sénateurs son inquiétude sur cette
future loi sur le renseignement voilà
tout de suite donc on écoute Francis
Delon
mes chers collègues nous sommes réunis
pour procéder à l'audition de Monsieur
Francis Delon
qui est le candidat proposé par le
Président de la République aux fonctions
de président de la Commission nationale
de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement cette audition
se déroule en application de la loi
organique du 23 juillet 2010 relative à
l'application du cinquième alinéa de
l'Arsène 13 de la Constitution
vous allez pouvoir entendre monsieur
Delon je lui propose s'il le souhaite
de commencer cette audition dans un
instant par un bref exposé
liminaire vous vous souvenez que cette
Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignements et créé par
la loi que nous venons de voter sur mon
rapport et dont j'ai oublié la date mais
vous la connaissez tous
et cette commission est dotée de pouvoir
très étendu d'abord de pouvoir
consultatifs mais aussi des pouvoirs de
contrôle et enfin du pouvoir pour
certains de ces membres de saisir le
Conseil d'État c'est même sur ce point
l'un des apports de notre discussion au
Sénat sur le texte nous avons voulu
rendre réellement effectif le contrôle
du Conseil d'État sur les décisions du
Premier ministre en matière de mise en
œuvre de techniques de renseignement
monsieur Delon a
exercé de multiples fonctions il est
conseillé d'État entré au Conseil d'État
en 1980
il a exercé d'abord des fonctions au
ministère des Affaires étrangères à la
direction des affaires juridiques c'est
mes souvenirs sont bons au cabinet du
ministre également comme directeur
adjoint du cabinet entre 1986
et
1988 il a également été le conseiller
juridique du représentant permanent de
la France auprès des Nations Unies à New
York
et puis parmi d'autres fonctions
il a aussi et c'est cette fonction qui
lui donne le plus d'expérience directe
des responsabilités qu'ils pourraient
être amenés à exercer si de commissions
celle de du Sénat celle de l'Assemblée
nationale donne le feu vert il a été
secrétaire général de la Défense
nationale
et
il a connu d'autres expériences qui ont
encore renforcé son expérience
internationale puisqu'il a également été
le patron de Radio France Internationale
je me trompe oui
c'est une erreur je
commence
ah c'est ça voilà bon donc nous
n'inscrivons pas ce point au procès
verbal de notre réunion voilà et
maintenant Francis Delon est devant nous
et je lui laisse bien volontiers la
parole pour qui nous expose la
conception qu'il se fait de cette
fonction qui lui est proposée
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
comme le président de votre commission
vient de l'indiquer je suis auditionné
ce matin devant vous
parce que après que le vice-président du
Conseil d'État m'a désigné en
application de la loi pour faire partie
de la Commission nationale de contrôle
des techniques de renseignement le
président de la République m'a pressenti
pour exercer la présidence de cette
commission
alors cette commission
elle est l'une des créations de la loi
sur le renseignement du 24 juillet
dernier
cette loi est le fruit d'une longue
maturation à laquelle le Parlement a
apporté une contribution décisive et je
dirais que face à vous qui en êtes les
co-auteurs sur membres de points très
important
je n'aurais pas
l'outrecident ni l'imprudence d'ailleurs
d'en faire l'exégèse je me bornerai en
énoncer les lignes de force que j'en ai
retenu
et qui pourrait guider mon action si je
suis désigné en fonction de président de
cette commission
la loi d'abord affirme que les services
de renseignement exercent une mission de
service public elle renforce à ce titre
leur légitimité et elle accroît leur
capacité d'action
elle fixe très soigneusement le cadre
juridique de leurs activités en veillant
à ce que ce cadre répondent à la fois au
défi auquel ces services sont confrontés
en matière de sécurité et à l'exigence
de respect de la vie privée dans toutes
ses composantes
elle renforce le contrôle de l'action
des services de renseignement en créant
précisément cette nouvelle autorité
administrative indépendante au pouvoir
de contrôle accru par rapport à la CNCIS
et en organisant l'accès au contrôle
juridictionnel du Conseil d'État
ce contrôle est destiné à vérifier que
la teinte que peut porter
au respect de la vie privée la mise en
œuvre des techniques de renseignement et
strictement proportionnées aux finalités
définies par la loi qui peuvent seule
justifier l'intervention des services de
renseignement c'est donc une loi de
protection des libertés publiques
et la commission de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement qu'elle crée
à vocation à jouer à cet égard un rôle
éminent
alors suis-je qualifié pour présider
cette commission
pour éclairer votre jugement je vais
brièvement me présenter et vous dire
quelques mots aussi du projet que en
vivant visage pour la commission si je
suis nommé à sa tête
votre président vient d'indiquer
rapidement les quelques étapes de mon
parcours
je rappellerai simplement quelques
points j'ai été nommé au Conseil d'État
en fait en 1979 mais j'y ai exercé
pendant une durée totale de 15 ans des
fonctions juridictionnelles
à la section du contentieux du Conseil
d'État où j'ai été rapporteur puis
commissaire du Gouvernement et enfin
président d'une sous-section
c'est-à-dire d'une chambre
et j'ai aussi exercé au Conseil d'État
des fonctions consultatives à la section
des finances et à la section de
l'intérieur où je siège actuellement
et puis j'ai par ailleurs occupé mes
Philippe ball a dit à l'instant
plusieurs fonctions hors du Conseil
d'État à plusieurs reprises dans ma
carrière
d'abord au ministère des Affaires
étrangères dans la direction des
affaires juridiques de ce ministère au
cabinet du ministre des Affaires
étrangères puis à la délégation
permanente de la France auprès des
Nations Unies à New York
ensuite j'ai exercé des fonctions
ministères de l'Éducation nationale j'y
étais directeur chargé des affaires
juridiques et de la coopération
internationale et j'ai exercé les
fonctions de directeur du cabinet du
ministre qui était à l'époque François
Bayrou
et plus récemment et jusqu'en 2014 donc
il y a un an
j'ai été à la tête du secrétariat
général de la Défense nationale puis du
secrétariat général de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale qui l'a remplacé
lorsque j'ai été pressenti pour la
présidence de la cnctr je me suis
demandé si j'y étais préparé
et il m'a semblé que tel était le cas
la fonction réclame je crois une
expérience juridictionnelle que j'ai
les fonctions juridictionnelles
préparent en effet à la collégialité et
au contrôle de proportionnalité que la
Commission devra exercer pour s'assurer
que les techniques de renseignement
envisagées n'apportent pas une atteinte
excessive aux libertés publiques et tout
particulièrement au respect de la vie
privée
elles exigent l'indépendance et
l'impartialité dont la Commission et son
président devront faire preuve le
président devra aussi me semble-t-il
avoir une bonne connaissance des enjeux
de sécurité nationale du fonctionnement
des services de renseignement et des
techniques que ceci utilise
ce que l'on appelle le renseignement
technique après une place déterminante
dans la plupart des services de
renseignement du monde
une bonne compréhension de cette
dimension technologique ne peut donc
faciliter l'exercice du contrôle
mes fonctions de secrétaire général de
la défense et de la sécurité nationale
me donnait autorité
sur l'Agence nationale de sécurité des
systèmes d'information là ainsi
qui remplit une mission de protection
des systèmes d'information de l'État et
de ceux des opérateurs d'importance
vitales
ces fonctions m'ont permis d'acquérir
une solide connaissance des enjeux de
sécurité nationale et d'appréhender sans
être un ingénieur la dimension
technologique du cyberespace alors je
sais que cette expérience peut faire
douter certains de mon indépendance à
l'égard des services de renseignement je
veux les rassurer connaissance ne
signifie pas connivence ni complaisance
mon indépendance à l'égard des services
était complète lorsque j'exerçais les
fonctions de secrétaire général de la
défense et de la sécurité nationale la
loyauté qui me dit au président de la
République et au Premier ministre ne
s'étendait naturellement pas au service
de renseignements
et l'ensemble de ma carrière au Conseil
d'État dans les fonctions
juridictionnelles et consultatives que
j'y exercé que j'exerce toujours
témoigne de mon indépendance
cette indépendance qui est la marque de
cette institution permet vous le savez
si le gouverne même si le gouvernement
en est contrarié d'annuler un acte parce
qu'il est illégal ou d'émettre un avis
défavorables sur un projet de loi ou de
règlement parce que ce projet soulève de
sérieuses difficultés juridiques
indépendance impartialité recherche
constante de l'équilibre voulu par la
loi entre la protection des libertés
publiques et la protection de notre
sécurité quelles sont les principes qui
me guideront si je suis nommé président
de la cnctr alors quel est mon projet
pour la cnctr si j'en prends la
présidence
ce projet je le veux à la fois ambitieux
mais aussi pragmatique
ambitieux parce que je veux dès
l'installation de la commission
relevez le défi que la loi a lancé c'est
à dire exercer dans un champ nettement
plus étendu un contrôle renforcé par
rapport à celui qui exerce aujourd'hui
la CNCIS
il faut pour cela davantage de moyens
que ceux dont disposé la CNCIS pour
pouvoir traiter dans des délais très
courts à fixer la loi un flux de demande
qui va croître très substantiellement
Jean-Marie Delarue auquel je veux rendre
ici hommage pour l'action courageux ce
qu'il a mené à la tête de la CNCIS
a heureusement anticipé en accord avec
le cabinet du premier ministre la montée
en puissance de la Commission en
obtenant des arbitrages qui prévoit une
hausse substantielle des effectifs et
des moyens
la première tâche du président de la
commission devra de s'assurer de
l'obtention effective de ses moyens de
vérifier s'ils sont adaptés de recruter
de nouveaux agents dotés des compétences
nécessaires notamment juridiques et
technologiques et d'organiser en
fonction des exigences de l'urgence et
du volume des demandes le travail de la
commission et de ses agents
un projet ambitieux parce que je
souhaite tirer parti de la composition
de la commission qui réunira des
compétences éminentes et faire de la
collégialité un élément de son
efficacité et de son autorité
et le collège sera très vite sollicité
et il le sera fréquemment notamment dans
les premiers mois durant lesquels il
devra rendre un avis sur plusieurs
textes réglementaires importants prendre
parti sur l'organisation pratique du
contrôle a priori comme a posteriori et
commencer à bâtir la jurisprudence de la
cnctr
ambitieux aussi parce que je souhaite
dans l'intérêt de l'efficacité de la
lisibilité du contrôle
développer le dialogue de la cnctr avec
les services notamment par des auditions
des chefs de service par la commission
et par des visites de la Commission dans
les services pour mieux être en mesure
de peser en pleine connaissance de cause
les avis qu'il sera amenés à rendre sur
les demandes d'autorisation chaque
membre de la Commission doit connaître
le fonctionnement des services et les
défis auxquels ceux-ci sont confrontés
chaque service devra connaître la
commission pour mieux comprendre les
raisonnements qu'elle tient et la
logique des avis qu'elle rend
ambitieux enfin parce que je crois
indispensable de bâtir la confiance du
public sur la qualité du contrôle
qu'exercera la cncts et j'attacherai
notamment
un soin particulier au contrôle de
l'agglorithme qui nourrit beaucoup
d'inquiétudes en m'appuyant sur les
compétences de la personnalité qualifiée
désignée par le président de l'ARCEP et
sur celle des ingénieurs de haut niveau
qui vont venir renforcer les services de
la Commission je veillerai aussi à ce
que la Commission développe une action
de pédagogie sur sa mission
ce projet devra néanmoins être
pragmatique
si les capacités de la commission
doivent nécessairement et notablement
augmenter la structure doit aussi
demeurer légère pour être efficace et
réactive
et comme une phase de montée en
puissance que je souhaite la plus brève
possible et inévitable je concentrerai
les moyens dans cette première phase sur
le contrôle a priori qui doit continuer
à s'exercer sans discontinuité entre la
CNCIS et la cnctr et au fur et à mesure
de l'arrivée de nouveaux moyens le
contrôle apostériori sera renforcé la
centralisation des renseignements
collectés nécessaires pour permettre un
contrôle à postériorer effectif devrait
être réalisé en prenant en compte les
impératifs de sécurité et les capacités
techniques disponibles la possibilité de
recourir davantage à des procédures des
matérialisées qui offrent des garanties
adéquates de protection du secret sera
également attentivement étudié
voici les quelques éléments que je
voulais vous livrer ce matin à titre
liminaire avant de répondre aux
questions que vous souhaiterez poser
merci Monsieur le Conseiller d'État je
vais tout de suite donner la parole à
ceux qui ceux et celles qui souhaitent
la prendre
mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président sueur monsieur Marc madame
taska
ça y est
et puis merci pour vos propos nous avons
été très attachés je crois les uns et
les autres lors du débat sur ce texte
important qui a créé l'institution
à la fois sur la nécessité de disposer
de tous les moyens pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et donc d'être très
efficace en termes de renseignement et
deuxièmement de préserver et de défendre
des libertés publiques et ça a été un
équilibre c'est un équilibre qu'il n'est
pas facile
peu d'atteindre mais auquel nous sommes
je crois très largement attaché
dans
ce contexte je voulais simplement vous
demander
bon vous avez dit votre
indépendance et je crois en effet que
les fonctions exercées antérieurement
n'appellent pas de commentaires par
rapport à l'indépendance évidemment
vous avez lu le dernier rapport de la
CNCIS qui fait état du fait que 1/4 des
avis défavorables rendus par cet instant
n'ont pas été suivi par le gouvernement
ce qui était d'ailleurs le droit absolu
du gouvernement le droit régalien
on est vous serez dans un nouveau
contexte où il sera possible de saisir
le Conseil d'État e égard à des
considérations qui tiennent en
particulier à l'urgence je pense que
vous aurez l'occasion de le faire le cas
échéant que vous ne vous priverez pas de
le faire vous et vos collègues une
préoccupation était apparue quant à la
capacité de l'institution la cnctr à
disposer de l'ensemble des
renseignements dont elle a besoin de
manière
facile
puisque il y aura forcément dispersion
des 10 renseignements donc la question
était posée elle a même été posée
publiquement je vais vous demander votre
appréciation à cet égard il est certain
que la question des moyens dont vous
disposerez et tout à fait importante
enfin
vous savez que nous avons pu obtenir au
Sénat que le ministre de la Défense
s'engage à ce que la cnctr puisse avoir
accès à ce qui s'appelle BND qui est la
plateforme nationale de décryptage ou de
décryptement je ne sais pas comment on
dit exactement qui dépend de la DGSE
mais qui est mutualisé entre les
services de renseignement je pense qu'il
s'agit là d'une nouveauté puisque jamais
aucun gouvernement n'avait fait une
telle déclaration je voulais savoir si
vous rentriez utiliser cette possibilité
je pense que vous le ferez mais j'ai une
question accessoire à ce sujet et je
termine monsieur le Président vous savez
que suite à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel
par rapport à qui a annulé qui a déclaré
qu'une partie de la loi relative aux
opérations extérieures qui n'était pas
conforme à la Constitution une
proposition de loi a été déposée qui
sera examinée je crois sous très peu de
temps par l'Assemblée nationale je
voulais vous demander je vais pas vous
demander ce que vous pensez de la loi
quelle est votre appréciation quand au
contenu de cette proposition de loi
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Marc
merci Président Monsieur le Conseiller
d'État vous avez évoqué la nécessaire
hausse des moyens parallèle à la montée
en puissance de de votre commission mais
au-delà des mots est-ce que nous avons
la certitude d'avoir ces moyens là et
quel sera leur traduction réelle
merci chers collègues madame taska
oui Monsieur le Conseiller d'État une
question un peu
marginale mais pour compléter la
présentation que vous avez fait
vous-même de votre parcours vous n'avez
pas du tout évoqué les
diverses collaborations que vous avez vu
avec le ministère de la Culture et je
pense en particulier à votre présence à
la BNF
ce que vous avez fait longuement dans la
commission de classification des des
films je crois vous avez travaillé aussi
sur le réseau des multiplexes je
voudrais savoir ce que ces différents
passages ont apporté à votre réflexion
puisqu'il se trouve que sont quand même
des champs dans lesquels la l'éventuelle
dualité entre liberté et nécessaire
ordre pour l'intérêt général sont des
questions
naturelles aussi
t-shirt collègues monsieur Jean-Yves
Lecomte merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Conseiller d'État de deux
questions la première un peu dans la
foulée de la réponse que vous avez faite
à l'Assemblée nationale sur la capacité
de la scène c'est-à-dire de saisir le
Conseil d'État en cas d'avis défavorable
votre réponse en fait
concentre les motivations qui pourraient
que la scène c'est-à-dire pour avoir
à recourir au Conseil d'État si le
premier ministre autorise malgré un avis
négatif de la Commission a finalement la
qualité de l'argumentation du Premier
ministre est-ce que vous évacuez
absolument
tout ce qui pourrait vous conduire à
douter de l'utilité de cette
de cette intrusion à la suite des des
premières des premières démarches des
services qui leur est faite ce que vous
concentrez vraiment sur cette cette
motivation du Premier ministre la
deuxième c'est une question sur les
moyens parce que j'ai noté aussi que
dans l'audition à l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez donné des chiffres des
chiffres qui finalement sont pas énormes
parce qu'il s'agit d'une d'un budget
multiplié par 4 ma femme x 4 quand on
est un peu plus de 100.000 euros
ou un peu plus de multiplication par
deux en termes d'effectifs mais on était
à 7 dont aucun ingénieur à la SNCF
jusqu'à 2014
est-ce que compte tenu de tout ce que
vous avez à faire parce qu'il y a plus
il y a pas que les inscrits les les
interceptions au téléphone il y a tout
le reste il y a les conservations durées
qui sont différentes il y a un contrôle
a priori et a posteriori les algorithmes
finalement on peut comprendre qu'il y a
une montée en puissance nécessaire parce
que les compétences c'est n'arriveront
pas d'un seul coup mais est-ce que
finalement lorsque vous
vous présentez globalement le projet on
y adhère toutefois cette multiplication
par 4 j'imagine que c'est le début d'une
montée en puissance parce que compte
tenu de tout ce qu'il y a en termes
toutes les compétences de la scènecter
ça ne peut pas s'arrêter là et en
particulier en termes de compétences
techniques c'est pas avec 400 000 euros
que vous pourrez avoir des ingénieurs
capables de comprendre ce qui se passe
je vous remercie chers collègues je vais
ajouter quelques questions au vôtres
tout d'abord Monsieur le Conseiller
d'État pour vous dire que le Sénat c'est
montrer dans la discussion
particulièrement attachée au contrôle
parlementaire c'est d'ailleurs à son
initiative sur ma proposition et celle
du président de la commission de la
défense et des Affaires étrangères
monsieur Raffarin que la loi organique a
été modifiée pour que nous puissions
auditionner la personnalité pressentie
pour exercer les fonctions de Président
je voudrais vous demander
premièrement quels sont les relations
que vous souhaiteriez nouées avec la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
et deuxièmement puisque nous avons
quatre parlementaires présents dans la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement mais que
nous avons souhaité différencier les
rôles des membres de cette commission
comment vous comptez faire vivre cette
collégialité à deux étages au sein de
cette institution que vous pourriez être
amené à présider enfin je voudrais c'est
dans un autre ordre de domaine vous
demandez si vous souhaitez établir dès
le départ le programme des contrôles sur
place
des services de renseignement
en matière de contrôle a postériori et
qu'elle est tendue vous comptez donner à
cette partie de la mission de la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement vous avez la
parole je me permets de vous signaler et
puis y avoir un rebond si tel ou tel de
nos collègues veut poser à la suite de
vos réponses une autre question que nous
n'avons que jusqu'à
9h moins 5 voilà vous avez la parole
je vais être discipliné en termes
d'horaire bien sûr
monsieur le Président si vous le
permettez je vais peut-être répondre aux
questions dans l'ordre dans lesquelles
elles ont été posées certaines de mes
réponses vont se recouper avec d'autres
questions puisque
certains termes sont communs à ces
questions et donc je l'ai mentionnerai à
chaque fois la question des moyens alors
monsieur Sueur vous l'avez vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur Marc vous l'avez
également
évoqué et Monsieur
le compte je crois là oui vous l'avez
également mentionné
alors c'est une question évidemment très
importante
car de quoi parlons-nous ici nous
parlons de l'effectivité du contrôle
qu'est-ce que la loi a voulu
la loi a voulu
donner plus de moyens au service de
renseignement une légitimité accrue ils
ont une loi si je puis dire à la
contrepartie c'est plus de contrôle
et c'est un élément tout à fait clé donc
il faut s'assurer que c'est le cas alors
ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui et ce qui a
été négocié par Jean-Marie Delarue je
l'ai mentionné tout à l'heure
c'est une montée en puissance qui fera
passer les effectifs selon les
arbitrages qui ont été rendus que je
connais pour l'instant encore
partiellement et enfin j'en connais les
grandes lignes
c'est de faire passer les ce qu'on
appelle les équivalents temps plein de
la Commission à 18 d'ici la fin 2016
et de voir les crédits d'investissement
et de fonctionnement augmenter d'une
façon très significative pour permettre
précisément les missions de contrôle à
posteriori qui pourront être exercés et
pour permettre aussi peut-être à la
Commission de ce doter de moyens
techniques plus développés alors
Jean-Marie Delarue a estimé je lui ai
parlé que
ces arbitrages
correspondaient aux besoins dont je lui
fais confiance puisque il avait une
vision que je n'ai pas pour l'instant
sur effectivement ce que fait la
commission mais bien évidemment et c'est
un point qui me paraît essentiel la loi
dit que la Commission doit disposer des
moyens nécessaires
donc il y a là une clause d'inventaire
qui est à faire et très rapidement
la Commission et le président de la
commission devront vérifier si ces
moyens sont adaptés s'ils sont
suffisants donc je crois que oui la
volonté du gouvernement et du Premier
ministre et de donner à la commission
ses moyens le Premier ministre la dit
clairement dans les débats
parlementaires et je n'ai aucune raison
de douter de la volonté du gouvernement
de d'aller dans ce sens l'intérêt du
gouvernement c'est du Premier ministre
c'est qu'il y ait un contrôle effectif
je rappelle que la loi fait peser
clairement la responsabilité politique
sur le Premier ministre tout premier
ministre quel qu'il soit aura à cœur
c'est son intérêt politique de veiller à
ce que le contrôle soit bien rempli donc
je n'ai pas de doute là-dessus
juste un mot pour vous dire nous avons
profondément remanier le texte du
Gouvernement sur ces questions le
président de la commission et le patron
c'est lui qui recrute si
vous estimez un jour en tant que
président de la commission
que vous n'avez pas les moyens
nécessaires le Parlement est en
particulier le Sénat seront
naturellement à vos côtés et compte tenu
de l'indépendance de cette fonction que
vous exercez nous souhaitons je parle au
nom de mes collègues que vous n'hésitez
pas à nous faire part des difficultés
éventuelles que vous pourrez rencontrer
si toutefois
le raisonnement très logique de
responsabilité que vous venez de nous
présenter à l'égard du gouvernement ne
donnait pas son plein effet
je vous en remercie enfin je ne voudrais
pas que mes paroles soient prises pour
de la naïveté
encore une fois nous verrons comment
cela se passe à l'usage en tout cas je
n'ai pas d'inquiétude sur la capacité
que la commission aura d'obtenir des
moyens voilà mais je veillerai bien sûr
si je suis nommé président de la
commission est-ce que ces moyens soient
effectivement détenus par la Commission
alors la question de l'avis défavorable
que vous avez également posé monsieur le
Président sueur
quand on regarde sur le long terme
l'histoire de la CNCIS il y a très peu
de cas dans lesquels cette commission
n'est pas suivi très peu de cas il y en
a eu quelques-uns dans la période
récente plus statistiquement que
d'habitude c'est souligné par le dernier
rapport de la de la CNCIS
je ne suis en tout cas
j'indique que il n'est pas souhaitable
qu'il y ait de nombreux avis
défavorables il peut y avoir des
circonstances dans lesquelles chacun
prend ses responsabilités et ce n'est
pas la commission qui décide elle donne
un avis
elle donne son avis en son âme et
conscience mais pour des raisons qui
relèvent de la responsabilité du Premier
ministre il peut y avoir des cas où le
Premier ministre n'est pas de cet avis
et la Commission peut maintenir sa
position et elle peut la maintenir et
aller jusque à la saisine du Conseil
d'État si elle estime que en dépit des
explications données je rappelle que si
le premier ministre n'est pas d'accord
il doit expliquer pourquoi il doit
donner les motifs à la commission très
vite et bien la Commission pourra saisir
le Conseil militaire c'est une notion
qui est apportée qui est importée par la
loi et cette saisine du Conseil d'État à
mon sens la Commission doit l'exercer
sans crainte et sans main tremblante si
c'est nécessaire elle le fera je n'en
doute pas dans le même temps
je ne voudrais pas que
l'épicentre du contrôle bascule du côté
juridictionnel parce que ça ne serait
simplement pas gérable le temps du
contrôle juridictionnel n'est pas le
temps du contrôle exercé par une
autorité administrative essentielle que
les deux se conjuguent et se confortent
voilà ce que je voulais indiquer là
dessus
à propos de la saisine du Conseil d'État
j'en profite pour répondre à une
question que Monsieur Lecomte a posé
tout à l'heure
elle pourra s'exercer je vous le
confirme je le compte non pas seulement
dans ces cas-là mais elle pourra
s'exercer si alors que la Commission a
autorisé
la mise en oeuvre d'une technique de
renseignement elle s'aperçoit que cette
technique n'est pas utilisée à bon
escient elle demandera alors au Premier
ministre de corriger le tir si vous me
passez l'expression de faire cesser
cette opération et si elle n'a pas
satisfaction elle pourra saisir le
Conseil d'État oui je pense que cette
situation là existe donc ça n'est pas
uniquement dans l'hypothèse ou il y
aurait un désaccord à binicio au stade
du contre la priori entre le Premier
ministre et la commission que cette
usine pourrait avoir lieu donc je vous
confirme en effet ça n'est pas limité à
cela
monsieur le Président sueur vous avez
vous avez évoqué également l'accès des
de la Commission
à la plateforme utilisée pour
centraliser les éléments de
renseignement recueillis je note là
dessus les déclarations très précises
que dans le débat parlementaire Monsieur
Le Drian le ministre de la Défense a
fait le gouvernement s'est engagé
je crois savoir que aujourd'hui même
cet accès existe de la part de la CNCIS
donc c'est un point qui me semble très
clair c'est un point également qui est
indiqué d'une façon précise par les deux
propositions de loi qui ont été déposées
sur le contrôle international vous avez
mentionné également ce point chez le
président donc la commission évidemment
fera
usage de cet accès et d'une façon
générale je dois le dire
je souhaite que la Commission exerce la
plénitude des compétences que la loi lui
a donné elle a été créée pour ça donc
elle exerce bien entendu son droit
d'accès à cette plateforme
alors la surveillance internationale on
est ici dans dans le registre de quelque
chose que le Parlement n'a pas encore
adopté mais qu'il a proposé pour faire
suite à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui a dit joint qui a
déclaré un constitutionnel la
disposition de la loi sur la
surveillance internationale alors quand
je regarde les deux textes qui sont
assez proches celui de l'Assemblée
nationale et celui du Sénat avec des
quelques nuances
je constate d'abord qu'on est en
présence de disposition nettement plus
développée que celle qui figurait dans
la loi soumise au contrôle du Conseil
constitution et pourquoi je me direz
vous puisque la censure du Conseil
constitutionnel
apporté sur le fait que les législateur
n'avait pas exercer la plénitude de ses
compétences il fallait donc
effectivement aller plus loin donc on a
des précisions qui sont apportées je
note également que
désormais
et c'est une notion par rapport à la loi
de 1991 les opérations qui se déroulent
en dehors du territoire dans ce domaine
là l'opération internationale seront
contrôlés
d'abord autorisés par le Premier
ministre c'est dit clairement et
contrôlé par la commission alors ce
contrôle s'exerce selon des modalités
particulières la Commission a un accès
complet si j'ai bien lu les propositions
de loi un accès complet
aux techniques et aux renseignements
collectés
elle a un exerce pas cependant un
contrôle a priori
elle se prononce apostériori et elle
peut faire des recommandations au
Premier ministre pour lui demander de
faire cesser tel ou tel surveillance
donc c'est un texte pour le Parlement
est saisi je dirais que c'est un texte
notamment sens la commission lorsqu'elle
sera constituée devra également débattre
et sur lequel elle devra se faire un
avis si le Parlement la consulte s'il
estime de voir la consulter elle donnera
évidemment son avis donc tout cela pour
vous expliquer que je m'exprime avec une
certaine prudence ce matin d'abord c'est
un texte qui émane du Parlement
et c'est un texte sur lequel la
Commission peut être amenée à être
consultée donc je n'en dirai pas loin je
me bornerai à ces remarques mais si le
Parlement estime devant consulter la
commission elle s'exprimera pour aider
le Parlement comme l'a fait d'ailleurs
la CNCIS précédemment lorsqu'elle va se
le renseignement a été élaboré et
discuter au sein du Parlement mais je
dirais que globalement ce texte va dans
le bon sens les questions que la
Commission pourra se poser c'est est-ce
que les modalités de son contrôle sont
totalement adéquates voilà la question
principale qu'elle devra se poser et je
préférais que ce soit elle qui le dise
plutôt qu'une personne qui aujourd'hui
n'est rien sinon pressenti pour exercer
la présidence cette commission la
colligialité dont je parlais tout à
l'heure elle a son sens à mon avis donc
je préférerais que le président ne
préompte pas ce que pourrait être futur
président le cas échéant ce que pourrait
être l'exercice de cette collégialité
monsieur
Marc vous avez effectivement
par les moyens
j'espère avoir répondu aux questions
posées sur sur ces moyens
madame Pascal la ministre vous avez
évoqué le ministère de la Culture que
vous avez dirigé vous avez raison je
n'ai pas mentionné le ministère de la
justice parce que je n'y ai jamais
exercé de fonctions
autre que ponctuel je n'ai jamais été
détaché au ministère de la Justice au
ministère de la Culture pardon mais
j'ai travaillé à plusieurs reprises pour
le ministère de la Culture vous avez une
mémoire parfaite des choses
j'ai siégé au conseil d'administration
de la Bibliothèque nationale je l'ai
fait pendant quelques années sous la
présidence de Monsieur Jeannet et je
l'ai fait aussi par goût des affaires
culturelles qui qui m'ont conduit à
travailler à plusieurs reprises pour le
ministère de la Culture j'ai présidé
pendant plusieurs années la commission
de contrôle des oeuvres
cinématographiques qu'on appelle souvent
la commission de censure mais qui n'est
pas du tout une commission de censure
parce qu'elle ne censure rien il n'y a
plus de censure en France en matière
cinématographique depuis longtemps
et effectivement cette dans cette
commission que fait-on on voit des films
et on délibère c'est une commission au
nombre de membres importants au siège
des professionnels ou siège des
défenseurs de la jeunesse ou siège des
représentants des administrations et
l'objet de cette commission c'est de
veiller à ce que les films
qui sont projetés
soit destiné au public
a véritablement aller voir autrement dit
en l'occurrence ce qu'on protège ce sont
les jeunes c'est la jeunesse éviter
qu'un film très violent qu'un film un
contenu sexuel fort depuis cette revue
par des enfants voilà ce que fait la
commission donc elle en débat c'est un
débat très riche
parfois conflictuelle et ça ne vous
surprendra pas compte tenu de ce que je
viens de dire sur la composition de la
commission et qui aboutit finalement à
une position ensuite qui est admise par
tout le monde le rôle du président c'est
de d'animer cette maïeutique oui alors
d'une certaine façon même si le domaine
est très différent de celui des
techniques de renseignement il y a
là-dedans un apprentissage de cette
manière de procéder et par ailleurs pour
le ministère de la Culture j'ai
également fait pour Madame trottman à sa
demande un rapport sur les multiplexes
un sujet on est aussi dans le domaine
des signes du cinéma c'est un sujet qui
a beaucoup
mobilisé
les exploitants en matière de cinéma et
qui craignaient à juste titre que
l'extension des multiples Flex ne vienne
mettre en cause
l'activité notamment des salles d'art et
C et peut-être mettre en cause au-delà
de l'activité des salles d'arets essais
la production cinématographique de
qualité donc il a fallu trouver
des des aménagements qui permettent de
répondre à ces préoccupations c'est
effectivement ce que j'ai essayé de
faire dans le cadre de ce rapport
monsieur Lecomte vous avez je pense
avoir répondu à vos questions
sur la saisine du Conseil d'État et
également sur les moyens si ce n'est pas
le cas je suis prêt à compléter ces
réponses
je président Philippe balle vous avez
parlé du contrôle parlementaire par le
contrôle il s'exerce vous l'avez dit
effectivement ce matin il s'exerce ce
matin au Sénat il s'exercera cette
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale par
l'audition que j'aurai devant la
commission des lois
et n'importe quoi une atteinte excessive
aux libertés donc il y a entre les deux
me semble-t-il des domaines d'action
tout à fait complémentaires et je
souhaite pour ma part que le dialogue
avec la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement soit particulièrement
nourris alors la particularité de la
commission c'est que elle comporte comme
la CNCIS d'ailleurs des parlementaires
il y en aura quatre je ne connais pas
encore le nom de ces de ces
parlementaires je crois que on le
connaîtra bientôt les présidents des
deux assemblées vont les désigner mais
leur présence qui a été débattue si j'ai
bien compris aussi bien par l'Assemblée
nationale que par le Sénat faut-il qu'il
y ait des parlementaires qu'elle doit
être leur nombre la loi à trancher c'est
une richesse dans la Commission devra
faire le meilleur profit c'est-à-dire
que ces parlementaires
qui je l'imagine n'auront pas la même
disponibilité que les autres membres de
la commission mais ces parlementaires
doivent
apporter au sein de la commission leur
vision délu du peuple avec la légitimité
que tout à l'heure donne et prendre un
recul que peut-être spontanément dans le
travail quotidien on n'a pas toujours
donc moi je trouve que c'est une
garantie pour la commission c'est une
garantie pour le fonctionnement
démocratique de la Commission et pour le
bon exercice des compétences que la loi
lui a donné
et je dois dire monsieur le Président
que je n'arrive pas à relire ce qu'est
votre dernière question vous avez
certainement
souhaitez-vous établir dès le départ un
programme des contrôles sur place des
services de renseignement en matière de
contrôle a postérieur merci beaucoup
en tout cas le contrôle dans à mon sens
ne se conçoit que s'il est à la fois a
priori et a posteriori c'est la
condition de l'effectivité du contrôle
Jean-Marie Delarue la parfaitement bien
expliqué notamment dans le dernier
rapport de la commission je souscris
totalement à ce qu'il dit donc oui un
programme de contrôle devrait être
établi
la Commission en discutera nous verrons
comment ce programme de contrôle peut se
conjuguer avec la montée en puissance
que j'indiquais tout à l'heure et la
phase de transition que j'évoquais mais
le contrôle a priori est absolument
indispensable et nous veillerons
effectivement si tu un tel programme
monsieur le Président Mezard
merci monsieur le président
Monsieur le Conseiller d'État vous venez
de dire que vous souscriviez totalement
aux conclusions du rapport qui a fait un
président de la rue
j'ai auditionné il y a quelques jours en
tant que rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête sur les autorités
administratives dites indépendantes le
président de la rue qui nous a exposé
qu'il n'avait pas souhaité
présider la nouvelle Commission
compte tenu des réserves de fonds qu'il
avait
exprimé
je pense que vous ne devez pas partager
ces réserves de fond sinon vous ne
seriez pas là ce matin et il nous a
rappelé
que récemment le gouvernement était
passé outre à deux avis de l'actuel
commission
si cela se reproduisait régulièrement
quel serait votre position
merci monsieur le président
je clarifie peut-être ma position sur ce
que vous venez de dire
effectivement si
j'ai accepté de
d'être président de cette commission en
tout cas peut-être proposé pour la
présidence de cette commission
c'est parce que je souscris globalement
à ce qu'a fait la loi sur le
renseignement
je pense que
il faut avoir
sur l'application de cette loi
une attitude de grande vigilance
vigilance pour s'assurer que les moyens
on en a parlé longuement tout à l'heure
sont au rendez-vous que la Commission
est capable de remplir son office et
d'exercer un contrôle effectif
il me semble
que les conditions sont réunies pour que
ce soit le cas les conditions juridiques
et les conditions politiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai accepté d'être pressenti pour ce
poste de président de la commission je
n'aurais évidemment pas accepté
de présider une commission alibi vous
comprenez bien chacun peut le comprendre
c'est parce que je crois que la
Commission pourra remplir ses fonctions
mais ceci étant la vigilance est de mise
il faudra s'assurer et ce sera sans
doute une vigilance de tous les instants
que les moyens sont là
les moyens de toutes sortes on a parlé
tout à l'heure des moyens matériels ou
des moyens en nageant mais il faudra
aussi s'assurer que par exemple la
Commission a un accès effectif au
renseignement ce qui suppose une
organisation ce qui suppose des
procédures et j'ai noté avec
satisfaction que la loi prévoit que sur
ces procédures la Commission est
consultée donc je peux vous dire que
elle veillera ce que ces procédures
permettent effectivement que ce contrôle
effectif soit exercé
sur les avis
je me suis exprimé tout à l'heure je
crois que si la commission n'est pas
suivie elle a la possibilité de saisir
le juge administratif le Conseil d'État
et elle le fera si elle estime que la
divergence et d'une nature qui justifie
que le contrôle juridictionnel s'exerce
je n'ai aucun état d'âme à dire cela
devant vous
ça n'était d'ailleurs pas le cas pour la
précédente instance et
le président sera douté du pouvoir
propre de saisir pour son propre compte
mais aussi trois membres seulement sur
les neufs ce qui devrait pouvoir se
trouver s'il y a un doute sur une
décision du gouvernement pourront saisir
pourront saisir le Conseil d'État mes
chers collègues avez-vous pu poser à
Monsieur Delon toutes les questions que
vous souhaitiez lui poser
monsieur Richard puisque nous sommes à
la fin moi je voudrais plutôt adresser
une recommandation amicale à Francis
Delon j'espère la nomination
les services qui l'aura comme instant
sera comme fonction de contrôle et
ce que j'appellerai une épaisseur
hiérarchique
et les fonctions que vous avez exercées
vous ont placé tout en haut de cette
hiérarchie
c'est pas facile pour la commission
forcément d'arriver à dialoguer avec les
agents de base
des services
mais à mon avis il faut tout faire pour
y arriver parce que c'est la vraie
condition de la réussite
vous avez enregistré cette
recommandation souhaitez-vous
je la prends comme tel et je la remercie
très vite mes chers collègues nous
aurons à procéder à notre vote sur cette
candidature cet après-midi à 16h30 ce
vote précédera l'audition de Monsieur
Bernard Cazeneuve ministre de
l'Intérieur qui aura deux volets cette
audition d'abord sur le projet de loi
relatif au droit des étrangers en France
dont Monsieur buffet et le rapporteur et
ensuite sur le dispositif exceptionnel
d'accueil des réfugiés dans leur
rapporteur et Monsieur buffet
je vous remercie je vous dis à tout à
l'heure et je remercie bien sûr monsieur
Delon d'avoir répondu dans le détail à
nos préoccupations
voilà vous êtes donc pu suivre
l'audition de Francis Delon devant la
commission des lois Francis Delon et le
candidat choisi par François Hollande
pour diriger la future Commission
chargée de surveiller les écoutes